which is going to tell us about
polynomial optimization or the other
extreme hi everyone so this is joint
work with Maillol Ghosh wankered guru
Swami who Yong Li and mother Tulsi honey
three of which should be in the audience
right now yeah so I'll start by defining
the problem we're given a degree D
homogeneous polynomial F in n variables
and we'd like to maximize it over the
sphere right now for D equals 2 this is
just the famous spectral norm problem
right and in this talk I'm gonna use
this to norm of F to denote this
quantity so the maximum over the sphere
maximum magnitude over the sphere just
said it's a norm right do you cool too
it's a spectrum of a matrix right and
you know just like the spectral norm
this has a large number of connections
it captures a large number of problems
let's see some of these so Baraka dal
showed you know using via the 2 to 4
norm that for an Associated matrix of a
graph the graph is a small set expander
if and only if the two to four norm is
small and the two to four norm is
captured by the D equals four version of
our problem all right and then this
connections to quantum computing like we
are the QM a problem which is it would
be coupled version of the degree four
problem we're looking at okay and the
best hardness was poured using this
connection and then there's a slew of
works from tensor decomposition and PCA
I'm not gonna go over these and do them
justice but sorry right and yeah then
freeze and Conan showed the connection
to plant it click when you have a
polynomial with non-negative
coefficients this captures a certain
type of dense is a hyper graph problem
this also has connections to refuting
random CSPs and it goes on yeah but you
know this problem is really hard
recently kozakov showed that there can
be exponentially many critical points
for this problem as soon as you go to
three when D is 3 there are
exponentially many critical points but
when D is true there are only n the
critical points are exactly eigenvectors
of the
problem regarding hardness results the
hardness is also somewhat modest so
Gurewitz and Nesterov showed that it's
np-hard to exactly optimize when D is at
least three the hardness is something
like 1 plus 1 over poly n right
and then Baraka Dahl also showed that
it's ETH hard to get a 2 to the square
root log approximation when D is 4 and
beyond now as for algorithms the best
known algorithms are also somewhat
modest core tower and much also improved
on work of Healy and John by showing
sort of n over log n to the D over 2
minus 1 as an approximate I mean it's
homogeneous it's homogeneous it's a
degree dipole moment yeah
and I'll call that the D form
interchangeably in this talk because
it's more succinct ok yeah so and they
showed that and then Doherty and 1r
showed that if you take N to the N times
so the like n over epsilon levels of the
SOS hierarchy get a 1 plus epsilon
approximation to this problem and our
goal is to sort of interpolate these
results ok and so that's what we do so
we show that an end to the Q time you
can get roughly n over Q to the D over 2
minus 1 as an approximation ok this is a
smooth trade-off between the previous
results with the caveat that so we
stopped at constant factor approximation
and what's our motivation for this
basically we want to develop techniques
to analyze SOS in the sub-exponential
regime so to to the end of the epsilon
runtime algorithms just because this is
sort of the regime of interest for many
of the problems I mentioned and also
there are some well-known problems for
which we need sub-exponential algorithms
and SOS and we don't have them yet
maxcut being one of them yeah so the
regime of interest is of exponential and
we want to develop tools to analyze
worst-case problems and the sphere is
sort of it's one of the easiest test
beds for things like this our techniques
to establish this result are pretty
general they actually they actually work
for four different problems so when I
have a polynomial with non-negative
coefficients we get a square root of the
previous approximation factors we get n
over Q to the D over four minus half and
when we have sparse polynomials with M
being the sparsity we get square root of
M over key and time n to the Q again and
all of these all of these actually apply
to a service this means Q levels of our
servers
so today I'll just focus on this result
and more specifically also a weaker
version of this result I will show an
over Q to the D over 2 approximation an
end to the Q time okay and at the end
I'll briefly talk about how I get the
negative 1 back in the exponent okay so
our first step is to sort of reduce the
problem to a simpler looking problem by
just powering so I set capital F to be a
power of little F let Q be a multiple of
D I said capital F to be a little after
the Q already now it's it's easy to see
that if I have an N over Q to the Q over
2 approximation for capital F the 2 norm
of capital F then I have an N over Q to
the D over 2 approximation for little F
this is just because the D over R cubed
power goes on so I'm actually going to
show a more general result I'm gonna
show an n over Q to the Q or to
approximation in enter the queue time
for any degree Q homogeneous polynomial
ok so that's our new goal we have any
degree Q homogeneous polynomial and
we're gonna show n over Q to the Q over
2
so I need to start with some
preliminaries so I just want to talk
about this many to one correspondence
between monomials and tuples because
tensors are indexed by tuples matrices
are indexed by tuples and I'm gonna talk
about these all over the talk so
generally when I have a tuple I want
through IQ I'm gonna map it to X I 1
times X I 2 and so on till X IQ mmm
those are a couple of examples if you
want to see alright next I'm going to
introduce multi indices right so multi
index is just a multi set it's just a
way of representing a multi set the it's
it's a vector in natural numbers to the
N where the I ate element of the multi
index stores the multiplicity of the
element I in the multi set
so I'm also going to use this sort of
cardinality notation to denote the size
of the multi index or the size of the
multi set and this set is going to
denote the set of all multi indices of
size exactly Q this might be slightly
different from the optimization
literature where they usually use at
most Q and again there is a simple
correspondence between multi indices and
monomials so X to the gamma where gamma
is a multi index is defined to be just
the product of X I to the gamma I and
here sort of cardinality of gamma is
just the degree of x of the gamma lastly
I need to define what I call the orbit
of gamma this is the set of all tuples
that correspond to the same multi set so
again this is this can be thought of as
the set of distinct permutations of a
multi set okay
okay so now I can define this concept of
matrix representation which is pretty
inherent in SS so I have this gigantic
matrix indexed by Q Oh two tuples on the
rows and q 2 tuples on the columns and I
say that a matrix represents a
polynomial this is a similar similar
definition to a tensor representation of
a polynomial just be flatten it into a
matrix right if sort of this quadratic
form of the queue or tooth tensor power
of X is equal to the polynomial on every
point
so I say represent Steve this is true
for every X
okay let's look at a couple of examples
now let's look at the following
polynomial which is the l2 norm of X to
the Q eighth power here's one
representation of this polynomial for N
equals 3 and Q equals 4 right basically
I can put 1 in any entry of the form i j
IJ and this will represent that
polynomial and this is just the identity
matrix I could also put 1 in any entry
of the form AI jajay and that's what
this corresponds to ok and notice that
the spectra of these matrices are
drastically different so this has
maximum eigen value 1 this has maximum
eigen value n so the representation is
important so this comes to a relaxation
which is just captured by s.o.s notice
that the spectral norm of any matrix
representation of our polynomial is an
upper bound on the two norm of the
polynomial simply because extends our D
over 2 when X is a unit vector X 10 30
over 2 is also a unit vector right so
this is at most respect to norm of a
because it's just a quadratic form right
so then one can define the following
natural quantity which is minimise the
spectral norm of a matrix a plantation
overall matrix representations of the
polynomial and it turns out that SOS
captures exactly this slightly weaker
version of the SOS program is precisely
this at degree Q and we're going to
refer to this quantity as GSP following
baracan are installed I'll call it the
spectral norm of G hopefully that
doesn't cause any issues
okay so I mean it's it's just a standard
STP but is there like like constraints
you would throw away from SOS yeah sort
of the non-homogeneous ones it's the
homogeneous program is equivalent to
this so if yeah all the less than or
equal to Q degree constrain the less
than Q degree constraints if I if I
wrote the program on only homogeneous
polynomials of degree Q then that's
where I wrote correspond to
okay so what's our strategy I'm just
going to show that this super crude
estimate gets better and better as Q
increases in terms of Q okay the crude
estimate is this normalized max
coefficient or max normalized
coefficient the normalization so this is
the coefficient of G G gamma and I'm
dividing it by the square root of the
orbit size of gamma let's try and get
some intuition for this if I had if I
had a polynomial in a single monomial G
gamma times X to the gamma this is
precisely what both these quantities
come to up to two to the Q factors okay
in this in this and in this talk I'm
going to ignore two to the Q and this
notation ignores two to the Q because we
care about Q to the Q yeah the two norm
of a single term is precisely this and
the way to see this is just by
substituting X is square root gamma I
divided by square root of size of gamma
intuitively this is because sorry if you
have an index appearing many times so if
you have X I appearing with large power
you want to give it more weight okay so
basically this normalized max
coefficient we're going to show that
this is a pretty good proxy for the two
norm and the spectral norm of G but
first I'll take a slight detour and I
just want to talk about that biggest
result right note that if I take Q to be
n then this result implies that sort of
if I take the nth power of a polynomial
F and look at its max normalized
coefficient I can use this quantity and
I can pretty easily estimate this
quantity I can use this quantity to
understand sort of the two norm of
random polynomials and this is very
similar to like the method of trace
moments for random matrices it's this
it's the genetic tool that you can just
apply on any random matrix ensemble and
hope to estimate its maximum eigen value
so similarly one could view a result as
sort of a generic tool to estimate the
two norm of a random polynomial of
course there's a caveat you're looking
at much much
degree quantities okay so this has this
has degree N and to get concentration
you're going to look at a log n power of
these coefficients and so totally in
total you're looking at n log n degree
whereas in the trace method you usually
look at like poly log and degree okay so
back to our goal so
so that's orbit of ghana it's a the set
of permutations corresponding to two
gamma but yes as you as you noted it's
if I had a single monomial that's
exactly what would come up actually this
max shouldn't be here sorry
okay so so let's get back to our goal we
want an N to the N over Q to the Q to
approximation for a degree Q polynomial
and I'm gonna note that it's really easy
for multi linear polynomials and note
that when Q is large and I have a multi
linear polynomial I have a lot of
freedom and my matrix representations I
have roughly Q factorial positions to
move mass over and we're gonna do the
obvious thing we're gonna take a matrix
representation that just spreads the
mass equally across all of them so I'm
going to take the SOS symmetric or super
symmetric matrix representation by which
I just mean that when I permute this
tuple I get I get the same value and
it's easy to see that that's a matrix
representation of my polynomial just
coefficient divided by Q factorial
because it's multilinear it's always
exactly Q factorial okay and then I'm
going to use the trivial upper bound on
the spectral norm of this matrix by the
gershgorin circles theorem this is just
n to the Q root 2 times the max entry so
I'm just going to use a trivial upper
bound the L 1 norm of this row and then
let this be the max entry right now I'm
going to show a lower bound on the 2
norm of G in order to get my
approximation okay and to do that first
let's do some warm-up right let's let's
substitute this vector as sort of the
row position of this entry and this
vector is the column position and these
vectors can be realized as the
tensor of elementary basis vectors
because the rows are indexed by tuples
the columns are index by tuples and this
this will get value max entry if you
average these vectors you will get max
entry over 2 but this one it gives us an
end to the q over 2 approximation so we
can actually do much better right and
this is because we took an NSF symmetric
representation so we have Q to the queue
entries that have the same value okay
and we're going to exploit that fact so
now we're going to set Z to be the
average of the elementary vectors well
sort of I 1 through IQ again is is the
index of the max and
the max magnitude entry okay and I'm
gonna take the L to average of these
vectors in doing that I'll lose route Q
to the Q which is Q to the Q / - okay
and I'm gonna again Q to the Q so
overall again Q to the Q / - so G 2 norm
is that is at least Max entry times Q
the Q over 2 up to 2 to the Q factors
okay so this gives me my desired n over
Q to the Q or two approximation if you
combine it with this and this okay so
what do we do for non multilinear g we
basically decompose it into multi linear
parts and here is the decomposition that
we that we use it's so basically we
write a polynomial uniquely as the
following we write it as summation of X
to the two alpha times G - alpha of X
where each G - alpha of X is multi
linear okay how do we do this well it's
it's simple you look at each monomial
and you just take out the maximally
squared part so as an example in X 1
square X 2 X 3 you're going to take out
the X 1 square and classify X 2 X 3
under the alpha corresponding to X 1
square okay similarly for X 1 square X 2
square you're going to take out 1 and
classify that as the coefficient of G
corresponding to X 1 square X 2 square
again as a reminder g2 alpha is a
homogeneous multi linear polynomial and
as degree is Q minus 2 times size of
alpha okay so the GS have different
degrees corresponding to the size of
alpha that we take out the multi linear
part is the most important part okay
okay so again our goal is an N over Q to
the q2 approximation right in the non
multi linear case now let's recap what
we know so what we showed earlier I
didn't quite write it in this form but
what we showed earlier was this okay
this is that same coefficient chain of
inequalities that I showed in the
beginning
except sort of with this approximation
factor accounting for the degree of the
polynomial okay I'm just rewriting this
with G two alphas because these guys are
multi linear okay now what strategy will
just be to show the following inequality
we show that the polynomial G is
spectral norm divided by G is 2 norm is
that most the maximum of the ratio for
the multi linear parts and this is
actually this is the versatile part of
our proof this max coefficient max
normalized coefficient is
interchangeable this is the part that
allows us to get results for sparse and
non-negative and all these other
settings and yeah I mean you can really
whenever you understand the like an
approximation and s.o.s approximation
for the multi linear parts of the powers
of your polynomial you can apply this
that's what we're gonna try and show and
we're gonna do it in two parts so first
we're going to show that the spectral
arm is that most g2 alphas spectral
armed where by orbit of alpha and by the
way one can interpret orbit of alpha up
to two to the Q as square root of orbit
size of two alpha okay and similarly
we're going to show that the two norm of
G is at least the multi linear part
divided by orbit orbit of alpha I'm not
gonna have time to show the second
inequality but at a high level it's
tricky because of cancellations and to
show it we prove a kind of decoupling
inequality so I actually combining this
fact with what I showed you on the
previous page for capital G 2 alpha
yields the the thing I promised in the
beginning that that this max normalized
coefficient is a good estimate
all right let's quickly try and see a
high-level proof of this in this claim
okay again we're going to try and give a
matrix representation for little G right
and we're going to try and use matrix
representations of capital G to alpha to
construct it okay our first step is to
sort of classify these alphas by their
size okay because once we classify the
classify them by their size we'll
actually be able to construct a block
diagonal matrix so I'm gonna set H I to
be the part of little G just
corresponding to alphas of a certain
size so it's zero for example is exactly
the set of all multiplying monomials of
little G and H one is all the guys that
have a single X I square that I can take
out and then I'm going to construct my
matrix a plantation as the summation of
B 0 through B Q over 2
okay where each bi represents nhi
what we define be zero well we just did
this right this is just the super
symmetric representation of G not the
fully symmetrized representation of G
not because it's just the multi linear
part okay how do i define B one well
notice that I have this X I square that
I can split I can I can take the X I to
the row and I can take another exite of
the column and and what happens is I I
can fit these guys into blocks okay
they're disjoint blocks and I can put X
1 square times GX 1 square there X 2
square times GX 2 square there and X 3
square times the X 3 square there and
what I'm gonna do over here is just put
the best representation of of these guys
and now I'm just going to appeal to the
fact that the spectral norm of a matrix
is at most the spectral norm of the
blocks so this is this is a high-level
picture of what's happening we classify
the Alpha as by size and then we
construct a block diagonal matrix and we
actually have one a few of them so when
we take their sum we don't lose much we
actually lose on a 1 plus Q over 2 and
recall two to the Q is sort of small for
us so this is still small
okay but I did promise that I can get an
orbit of alpha in the denominator here
I'm not gonna go with this exactly but
at high level it's just because I
actually have orbit of alpha diagonal
blocks to average my mass over so I'll
actually take the best representation of
G to alpha and average it over orbit of
alpha or many places okay we're done
with that now how does one save one in
the exponent well we didn't use the fact
that quadratic case is easy so we're
just going to we just end up using this
and we kind of we think of a polynomial
as being a degree D minus two polynomial
with quadratic coefficients so we just
think of these coefficients I mean we
just think of these quadratic pole
polynomials as coefficients we peel off
and then think of them as coefficients
then we sort of reprove everything by
thinking of these as coefficients in a
Banach space okay
let's conclude yeah so can one
understand for degree for SOS what's the
tight answer so Hopkins at all showed
that n to the D over four minus half is
a lower bar and this comes from random
polynomials but the best upper bound is
n to the D over 2 minus 1 exactly the
square of this so there's this
interesting gap there I think this is a
fun question when D is 4 it's just root
n versus n I actually think the answer
is closer to 1 but a lot of people will
disagree with me yeah and secondly there
are no good hardness results can we get
better hardness results
[Applause]
so how do you results compare the sort
of these classical results if we have a
homogeneous polynomial positive from the
unit sphere you could ask you know by
what power of the sum of X I squared
that's a constant just one of the units
here I need to multiply it for it to
become a sum of squares all right and
then and there is there some some known
bounce there the the the sorry the the
degree by which you need to multiply
depends on the minimum of your function
on the units here you cannot hope that
there will be universal bound but
essentially what you're saying is I do
you know when I multiplied by the sum of
website square I really don't change my
polynomial on the unit sphere right it's
it's 1 in the unit sphere and they're
but you just try to decompose it really
as a sum of squares of polynomials of
higher degree so these are classical
results going for like you know it's
like 30 years back but I'm wondering
what there should be some relation
between that right um so for one thing I
guess even the minimization version of
this problem kind of behaves differently
so for instance for minimization to two
for norm we actually have hardness but
yeah I don't know off the top of my head
that's a good question but yeah I
actually think another proxy for higher
levels of SOS is multiplying sort of to
two norm to whatever power times the
polynomial instead of just taking powers
of the polynomial so it's possible
there's a correspondence I don't know
off the top of my head I'll look into it
Thanks
let's thank you
[Applause]